Infidelity is commonly interpreted as close
to the greatest tragedy that could befall
any relationship – and as the natural, inevitable
prelude to the break-up of a union. It is
viewed in such dark terms because, under the
philosophy of Romanticism which has dominated
our understanding of love since the middle
of the eighteenth century, sex is understood
to be, not principally a physical act, but
the summation and central symbol of love.
Before Romanticism, people had sex and fell
in love but they did not always see these
two acts as inextricably linked: one might
love someone and not sleep with them. Or sleep
with them and not love them. It was this dislocation
that Romanticism refused to countenance. Sex
was simply the crowning moment of love, the
superlative way of expressing one’s devotion
to someone, the ultimate proof of one’s
sincerity. What this philosophy unwittingly
accomplished was to turn infidelity from a
problem into a catastrophe. Never again could
sex be viewed as in any way divorced from
intense emotion and a profound desire for
commitment. It was no longer possible to say
that sex meant ‘nothing’, in the sense
of being a joyful, kind but emotionally-empty
act devoid of any desire to care for or live
with a new person in the long-term and in
no way indicative of any drop in affection
for the established partner. There are, of
course, many cases where infidelity means
exactly what Romanticism takes it to mean:
contempt for one’s relationship. But in
a great many other cases, it may mean something
really rather different: a passing, surface
desire for erotic excitement that coexists
with an ongoing, sincere commitment to one’s
life-partner. Our culture makes this thought
close to impossible, and so getting ‘over’
an infidelity – by which is meant, learning
to see that the unfaithful act might not mean
what Romanticism tells us it means – has
become a challenge of heroic proportions and
most of the time, a brute impossibility. However
much an unfaithful partner may patiently explain
that it meant nothing, the idea seems entirely
implausible. How could sex, the summation
of love, ever mean anything less than pretty
much everything? There may be one potential
way out of the impasse: a frank examination
of the recesses of one’s own mind and perhaps,
an honest recall of certain moments of past
personal experience. What this brave investigation
is likely to throw up is evidence that one
is strangely capable of something – in the
circumstances – really rather surprising:
caring deeply for someone and yet entertaining,
or masterminding, a sexual scenario involving
somebody else. However much the thought seems
unbelievable when we hear it from the mouth
of a straying partner, it does appear that
it is, in some ways, really rather possible
to think of screwing one person and loving
another. The best way to recover after an
infidelity may therefore be to ignore what
Romanticism tells us that infidelity has to
mean, and to consult instead a more reliable
source of information: what we ourselves took
infidelity to mean the last time the idea
crossed through our minds or our lives. It
is on this basis that we may – with considerable
pain of course – come one day to be able
to forgive and even in a way understand and
accept the apologies of a repentant partner.
It is on the basis of subjective experience
of unfaithful thoughts that we may redemptively
enrich, complicate and soften what happens
when we end up as their victims.
At The School Of Life we believe in developing emotional intelligence.
To that end we have also created a whole range of products to support that growth.
Find out more at the link on the screen now.